as he very rightly said Society has now
evolved before men went to war now men
don't go to war so there's a lot of
sense of no purpose that they need to
find and then on the women's side is
that the same way that a society evolved
and made men feel less purpose they have
now had to take on bigger purposes they
have to go to work like they didn't have
to do before they have to take care of
the family and work and do all of these
things and now deal with the fact that
men are feeling a little bit like out of
you know the rubbish saying what I'm
saying you can you get a nine to five
person right what is wrong with you
going out there find a regular nine to
five person right you can function
underneath that because I'm always
saying the women say oh we ain't got
enough money we ain't got enough money
work with what the man's got you're
right work with what the man's got you
can make a manual Alpha everybody wants
to go and find these top earning money
find a nine to five work regular save
your money learn to cook and not have
takeouts and then save your money as I
did before then you should direct this
to the men that feel upset because
they're not like